>> Trace: JOE BIDEN’S TEAM
CONFIRMING AT LEAST THREE
PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAMPAIGN HAVE TESTED POSITIVE
FOR CORONAVIRUS FORCING SENATOR
KAMALA HARRIS TO CANCEL TRAVEL
AT A CRUCIAL TIME AND
HIGHLIGHTING A STARK DIFFERENCE
IN MEDIA COVERAGE COMPARED TO
WHAT WE SAW WHEN HOPE HICKS WAS
FIRST DIAGNOSED WITH THE VIRUS.
THE HEADLINE OF THE ARTICLE IN
SALON.COM SAYING THE AUDACITY
OF HOPE HICKS AND HER BOSS
GETTING COVID-19.
JOE CONCHA IS A MEDIA REPORTER
FOR THE HILL.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I WAS LOOKING AT THE COVERAGE
AND DOING SOME HISTORY AND
GOING OVER WHAT HAPPENED A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO WHEN THE
WHITE HOUSE OUTBREAK HAPPENED
VERSUS NOW.
I FIND IT FASCINATING.
THIS IS ALTERNATE, A LEFT WING
PUBLICATION.
THEIR HEADLINE HERE ARE FOUR
WAYS BIDEN’S TEAM’S RESPONSE TO
POSITIVE COVID TEST SHOWS THE
BREADTH OF TRUMP WORLD’S
INCOMPETENCE.
AMAZING ONLY WHEN YOU HAVE AN
OUTBREAK OF COVID IN THE
CAMPAIGN CAN SOME BLAME THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
>> YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BRING
TRUMP INTO THE CONVERSATION
EVEN THOUGH IT’S A STORY ABOUT
JOE BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN AND KAMALA
HARRIS BEING TAKEN OFF THE
TRAIL.
I DON’T KNOW IF ANYBODY WILL
NOTICE THE SENATOR BEING TAKEN
OFF THE TRAIL.
I’VE NEVER SEEN A MORE
INVISIBLE CANDIDATE EVER RUN
FOR OFFICE OF THE STATURE IN
TERMS OF THE VP SINCE JOE BIDEN.
SHE HAS YET TO DO ONE PRESS
CONFERENCE, ONE GAGGLE WITH
REPORTERS, SHE HAS YET TO DO
ONE REMOTELY TOUGH INTERVIEW IN
ALL THIS TIME.
SO YEAH, KAMALA HARRIS WILL BE
TAKEN OFF THE TRAIL BUT WILL
ANYBODY REALLY NOTICE?
>> Trace: ARE YOU CURIOUS AT
ALL ABOUT THE LACK OF SCRUTINY
THAT THE POSITIVE TESTS IN THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN AND PEOPLE
ASSOCIATED WITH KAMALA HARRIS
IS GETTING IN THE MEDIA NOW?
YOU READ THE ARTICLES AND STATE
THAT SHE HAS HER COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND SOMEONE ON THE
PLANE AND SOMEBODY ELSE BUT
THERE DOESN’T SEEM TO BE A LOT
OF DEEP DIVE LOOKING INTO IT
THE WAY YOU WOULD THINK ONE
WOULD WANT TO KIND OF CONTACT
TRACE THIS IN THE MEDIA.
>> YEAH.
THAT’S JUST THE DEEP DIVES, BUT
THE CONDESCENSION, THE SNARK WE
SEE RELATED ALWAYS WHEN IT IS
SOMETHING ABOUT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN TERMS OF BLAMING
PEOPLE FOR GETTING COVID-19
AUTOMATICALLY ASSUMING IT WAS
RECKLESS BEHAVIOR IN TERMS HOW
THEY CONTRACTED IT.
IT’S A DICEY THING.
YOU ARE BLAMING THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO TESTED POSITIVE.
MAYBE THEY DID EVERYTHING RIGHT
AND MAYBE WE DON’T KNOW ABOUT
HOW TO GET IT.
IF I WERE TEACHING A ZOOM CLASS
IT WAS SELECTIVE OUTRAGE 101.
WITH TRUMP VERY DIFFERENT AND
WHAT WE’RE HEARING ABOUT NOW
WITH THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> I WANT TO MOVE INTO THE
STEVE SCULLY CONTROVERSY.
HE WAS GOING TO MODERATE THE
SECOND DEBATE THAT WAS CANCELED.
HE SAID HIS TWITTER ACCOUNT GOT
HACKED LAST WEEK AND DIDN’T
SEND THAT TWEET TO ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI.
AND NOW HE IS SAYING I DID SEND
IT.
I APOLOGIZE.
CHRIS WALLACE LAST WEEK WHEN
THE WHOLE THING BROKE.
WE HAD HIM ON A FEW MINUTES AGO.
HE SAID LOOK, HE GOT HACKED AND
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS NOT GUILTY
AND TODAY CHRIS SAID THIS,
WATCH.
>> UNFORTUNATELY AS WE’VE ALL
LEARNED IN OUR PROFESSIONALS
LIVES AND SOMETIMES IN OUR
PERSONAL LIVES, PEOPLE DO
THINGS YOU DON’T EXPECT THEM TO
DO.
THEY TURN OUT, YOU KNOW, TO
HAVE TOLD YOU SOMETHING THAT
TURNS OUT TO HAVE BEEN A LIE.
IT’S VERY SAD.
AND HE IS GOING TO PAY A PRICE
FOR IT.
ULTIMATELY THE COMMISSION PAYS
A PRICE FOR IT BECAUSE THEY
CHOSE HIM AS A MODERATOR.
>> Trace: WHAT’S THE PRICE IN
YOUR ESTIMATION, JOE, FOR THIS
MEDIA BIAS?
>> I THINK IT’S PERMANENTLY
DAMAGED REPUTATION
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS CASE,
TRACE.
I UNDERSTAND CHRIS WALLACE HAS
BEEN IN THE NEWS BUSINESS MORE
THAN 50 YEARS.
STEVE SCULLY 30 YEARS.
SOMEBODY WHO HE KNOWS GAVE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
I WAS ON LAST WEEK AND I WAS
SKEPTICAL.
I FOUND TWO THINGS ODD.
SCULLY DIDN’T PUT OUT A
STATEMENT THAT I WAS HACKED.
SILENCE WAS TELLING.
IF YOU HACK A PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE MODERATOR’S ACCOUNT IS
YOUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS TO
SEND THE SCARAMUCCI TWEET AND
YOUR ONLY ORDER OF BUSINESS AND
IT GOES AWAY?
THE DEBATE COMMISSION HERE
CANCELED THAT DEBATE T SECOND
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN
LAST NIGHT SO MUCH ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT HAVING COVID AND THE
RISK FACTORS.
IT WAS THE FACT THAT IF STEVE
SCULLY MODERATED THE DEBATE AND
THERE WAS SOMETHING FISHY IF
YOU IMAGINE THAT DEBATE WENT
OFF LAST NIGHT.
THERE IS AN F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION.
IT IS THE COVER-UP THAT’S THE
PROBLEM FOR STEVE SCULLY.
>> Trace: THIS IS ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI SPEENG OF CAN SEFMGT
HE SAID THIS.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO GOT THE
TWEET.
HE SAID I GET HE GOT SUSPENDED
MEANING STEVE SCULLY FOR THE
LIE.
THE PUNISHING CANCEL CULTURE IS
OVER THE TOP.
IS IT OVER THE TOP, JOE?
>> NO, IT IS NOT BECAUSE AGAIN
IF YOU HAVE THE F.B.I. AND
TWITTER INVESTIGATING THIS
AFTER HE LIED, THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ENOUGH.
ALL HE HAD TO DO IS SAY I WAS
JOKING AROUND, SENT SOMETHING
TO SCARAMUCCI, NOTHING TO SEE.
IT WOULD HAVE PROBABLY GONE
AWAY.
INSTEAD BY COVERING IT UP IT
LED TO HIM PROBABLY NOT WORKING
FOR C-SPAN A LONG TIME.
ONCE YOU LOOK AT STEVE SCULLY